you know my first thoughts this morning
are immediately with the uh
uh the boys that have done so well for
us
and uh the players have had an
incredible
um togetherness and spirit which i think
has brought
so so many parts of our country together
so
you know they should be and i i think
they are incredibly proud of what
they've done
um for some of them to be abused
is unforgivable really um i know a lot
of that has come from abroad you know
the people that track those things have
been able to
explain that um but not all of it and
um it's just not what we stand for
we we i think have been a
a beacon of light in bringing people
together in
people being able to relate to the
national team
and the national team stands for
everybody and um
so that togetherness has to continue and
we've shown
the power our country has when it does
come together and
has that energy and positivity together
we felt that from the fans
and um i'm incredibly proud of the
players
and as i said yesterday the
the game we we needed to win in 120
minutes
um we were a little bit short in that
period
then it's my decision who takes the
penalties it's not a case of
players not volunteering or you know
more experienced players backing out
they didn't have the chance that was my
choice
nobody else's um my my decision
to give the guys that took it the
penalties that they took
still got huge belief in them um
so those those boys have done a
a brilliant job and
we we heal together as a team now and
we're there for them and i know that
99 of the public will be as well because
they will appreciate how well they've
played bracayo in particular has been an
absolute star in this tournament
incredible maturity the way he's played
um
has brought a smile to so many people's
faces he's become
such a hugely popular member of the
group and uh i know
he's got everybody's support we've got
of course
to qualify for qatar um but
i need some time to go away watch watch
last night's game again
reflect on the whole tournament um
[Music]
you know i need a rest um it's um
amazing experience but you know to lead
your country
in these tournaments is um
[Music]
takes its toll and uh you know i i need
a break now
so it's um yes i said at the time it was
great to have that internal support you
you hugely value that as a manager
but also you know there's a lot a lot to
think through it's not about
um finance in any way or commitment you
know i i don't want to commit to
anything longer than
i should and i never want to outstay my
welcome
so um but
so all of those things need
consideration before even thinking about
uh sitting down and talking but
you know i as i sit here today i would
want to be
taking the team to qatar i feel that
we've made progress over the
the four years um
we've we've had a fourth place a third
place and a second place it's uh
probably as good as any other team in in
in europe by those that have won the the
the tournaments themselves but
for consistency it's it's right up there
so
um a lot of things we've done right and
we know
and this team isn't at its peak yet um
but that doesn't guarantee winning
because we know how difficult it is to
get back to
the stage we got to last night that's
why it's you know so painful to get so
close
look i think you're always learning as a
manager um
i've had the opportunity now to manage
some of the biggest games in world
football
so um those games take you through
an incredible roller coaster and there
are so many decisions to make across
the four or five weeks
you're never going to get them all right
and we would never claim to have got
them all right
and sometimes you win matches
despite certain decisions and sometimes
you lose matches when
maybe the they were still the right
decisions to make
so um it's all
all part of learning every every coach
every manager is going to reflect on
every game that they
take charge of and be better for all of
the experiences that you go through
so that that process is is never ending
really
yeah i think i need to see i need to
watch the game back it's
two and a half hours pretty much
where so much has happened that to be
able to go through the timeline of all
that now is
is uh yeah
there's too much going on during the
game since the game to really
be able to reflect properly so i i need
time to do that it's always important to
watch it back
and uh to to give a true account of that
i think
well we've wanted for a long time to
uh make playing for england fun
make playing for england enjoyable um
i think our players now have that you
know when they when they come away with
england
i think they've had a fabulous
experience they've they've loved the
adventure they've loved each other's
company um they've got
an incredible spirit it is you know it
really is
a club type spirit and um
[Music]
the the younger ones especially you know
they
well all that all of this team can go
again there's no there's no doubt about
that but the young ones are
still two four years from from peaking
and uh we've got 18 19 20 year olds
who've
done an incredible job and had a great
insight into tournament football and um
and acquitted themselves so well
throughout so
there are i know as i reflect over the
coming days there are a huge number of
positives from that
and those players will uh
will be far better for for going through
um
[Music]
so many important wins so many important
landmarks that they
they set historic performances
in the main they they performed under
the huge pressure of
being at home for the majority of the
tournament being one of the favorites
that was a far different situation to
the
team when we went to russia and they
dealt with that so well in the opening
game in the
game with germany in the semi-final for
a large part of the final certainly the
first half of the final you know they
they they dealt with that um and
we probably had a 20-minute period where
we didn't keep the ball
as well as we needed to just after
half-time
but then even the rest of the game was
fairly even although we couldn't create
um the clear chances that we've been
able to in the past
and uh part of that is because we were
against a team that have gone
30 games unbeaten and some
incredibly experienced players and a
team that are probably just a little bit
further ahead than us
in their development and their progress
when you're in sport and you get to
finals you know that those opportunities
are so rare and to be so close and
um to know what that's taken and to know
you've got to pick yourself up and go
again
that's that's very hard the day after
you know you you've
you've given everything and the energy
levels are low and
the emotions are drained so
we we will go again of course um but
yeah sometimes it's easy to say things
like oh you know
we can go on to guitar now and win and
you know it's a bit glib really it's
that's a long journey we've still got to
qualify we've still got
um steps to take and uh
yeah you've got all the complexities of
release of players throughout the
qualifying period and everything else
that you have to start
that cycle again so this has been
fantastic to have the time with the
players that we get
to be able to work with the players
every day
really embed the culture embed our way
of playing um
[Music]
those periods of what what you live for
as an international manager and of
course when it comes to the end it's uh
it's very difficult we picked a team
because of a tactical problem that italy
pose
and areas of the pitch we needed to get
pressure on them and where we thought we
could hurt them
and i think for the first 45 minutes
everybody would agree that
that worked we didn't keep the ball well
enough for a 15-20 minute period
and we know that with midfield players
of the quality of herati
georginio that is always going to be a
strength with italy so they are going to
have possession
um we were actually controlling the game
without the ball for long periods um but
at that period we
were a little bit um more open um
we then couldn't release that pressure
by keeping the ball which we had done so
well in the first half
we changed the shape which i think um
gave us a little bit more
[Music]
control but it did open up spaces
elsewhere so
any tactical change you you have
strengths
and then there are weaknesses to any
system they they went with a false nine
for a period which is difficult to
to deal with if your defenders step out
they leave spaces if they
stay in then you get overloaded a little
bit in midfield so that's always a
really difficult problem for any team to
solve
um and we didn't quite create the
chances
that we would have liked to but you're
against the team who are
incredible in terms of their defensive
power
as a team not just the two centre-backs
so yeah there are lots of things that
i will reflect on of course we we we do
that after every game and uh
um that that is the right process to go
through
but until you watch the game in in
absolute detail then
i would be uh i wouldn't be giving you a
fully accurate
uh appraisal of that you don't get to a
final without
so many players having played well and
that's what happened for us
so um jordan has often been
you know the number of times i've sat
here and he's his place in the team has
been questioned and uh
he's constantly delivered for us and uh
this tournament i think was was his best
run of performances for england
and he should be uh hugely proud of that
to concede two goals in seven matches
um you know our whole defense our whole
team but of course
the goalkeeper was a big part of that
two saves in the shootout
so you know he he could do a little more
in terms of keeping the ball out of our
net and um
that's always the the starting point for
any goalkeeper
so yeah he had a a a really outstanding
tournament
we've got to a final first time for 55
years
um
yeah i'm not sure um
[Music]
not really sure what what uh
a team that gets to a final you you're
not a nice team to get to a final
i think we've overcome a lot of hurdles
that we've never been able to in the
past
um we know that
a lot of players that are still
very inexperienced in terms of
international football and
and have delivered at an incredibly high
level
the more experienced players
in the big matches were really able to
use their experience to to defeat
germany who
who had an incredibly experienced team
to come through a semi-final which was
a hugely challenging
experience for them and we've taken it
to the
who are a top top team and an unbeaten
in 30 right to the wire
so if if we'd
been torn apart or or
you know we'd look to mess then i might
be thinking differently about it but
um of course we're going to analyze
everything but also
we're going to be realistic about that
and not just dive into things that
aren't
reality and aren't the reason for for
not having one
um it's easy to throw theories around at
the end of a
of any game in in any number of areas
but
i think it's important to really reflect
carefully and uh and analyze carefully
when when you're the coach because
um i i don't i don't want to go along
with narratives that are
that probably aren't correct um but also
i have to reflect on
on everything that's asked which is
totally fair when we looked back at
germany's winning
2014 they'd been to semi-finals and
um you know semi-final in their own
country when they hosted 2006 and
the pain of that but also the experience
of that and
yeah if you want sustained success as a
team
you have to constantly be evolving
constantly improving
constantly finishing in those later
stages and
um most teams that win you know france
went through what we're feeling now
2016.
germany did it as i said spain went
close a couple of times before they won
um that is normally part of the process
that you've that you have to go through
and
um the fact that we've had a you know
the first signs of some consistency
semi-final final
um it has to be a step in the right
direction it's not
ultimately where we wanted to get to and
when you're so close that's even more
painful of course it's
you know it feels like stomach's been
ripped out this morning
but um i know
when my logical brain comes back to life
in a few days that that is that is the
process we have to go through and we've
got to keep continuing that
and england have to keep that track
going you know
whoever is here whoever is at the fa
whoever's at st george's park
that's what we have to build that's that
was the vision at the start and
we're showing the signs with with the
help of the clubs who are producing
some fantastic young players um all of
those things have to align because
you know any part of that football
pyramid that isn't strong
um affects the national team and at the
moment lots of things are starting to
come together and we have to continue
that
we had seven i think in the starting
team
last night from uh from russia
and that experience um has been critical
through the big matches in this
tournament
so to add the young players in at the
times we did the inexperienced players
in at the times we did
they've now there's another group with
with more learning more understanding of
that high level
um they will because of what they've
been through in these two tournaments
they'll want more
they'll they'll know they can get close
they'll have belief
um and that's what we have to build on
it doesn't guarantee anything because of
course you have to start again and
you have to earn the right every time
you uh you take the field and every time
you go into a tournament but
the the cycle and the expectation of the
group
when they come together now will be no
no this is this is how it works this is
how we
train every day this is what's needed
this is
where we what we need to do to get to
the level to win
and um that that should be a process
that stands us in good stead
yeah we've got to make sure that we're
there and
aligned with their clubs and uh making
sure that we look after those boys
absolutely and
um that that's been top of my thinking
um all night really the obviously
there was a long period in the dressing
room last night
um they then went to meet with their
families
um across the road um so they had
you know i'm told they had a nice sort
of evening together
um i i managed to see them all
individually
for a few moments before they left the
dressing room because
i knew everybody would be sort of
heading their own direction at the end
of the game
and um i just wanted to thank thank them
all for what they've given because
they've been
a joy to work with they really have
bought into everything we've tried to do
um been totally unselfish in their
outlook
um they've all you know
given everything they possibly could so
i'm tremendously grateful for that and i
know the country is because
you know you you can sense from uh from
the reactions of people so
but yeah they're they're they're all
head on their way now um
they they they need a break they need a
rest and
uh uh i hope they all have a fantastic
summer
you know even coming into this
tournament there were so many things
that were uncertain in
in terms of being able to embed one way
of playing
um the injuries we came in with the
availability that we came in with
um we weren't quite sure defensively
what what we were gonna look with
um i have to say you know tyrone did a
fantastic job coming into
a massive situation at the beginning of
the tournament um
we we had that huge doubt over harry
maguire at the start
and to have defended as well as we did
throughout the tournament
um without having been able to play that
back four together too often really in
the
in the two years before luke only came
back in with us in march for for one
game
he had a phenomenal tournament i have to
say as well
so we we were constantly dealing with
uncertainties we didn't know
you know calvin phillips amazing
tournament we weren't sure we were going
to have him in the
the week leading into the first camp um
so remarkable yeah really in in terms of
trying to build something consistent we
never had the players
um all together until seven days before
the start of
of the tournament itself and you'd you'd
like to have built across the whole
season but that wasn't the realities of
the season we had that should be the aim
moving forward
in some areas of the team we've got
clear strength
and players who were in form
and in other areas of the team we don't
have quite the same amount of strength
and we've had to do it
differently and do it our way and by
adapting and adjusting we've
we've managed to get to a final so of
course you're always looking for
perfection and we're always looking to
improve and we must continue to do that
thanks matt okay we're coming to the end
now so we've got time for a couple more
i'm starting with rob harris from ap
hi garth commiserations thanks for
everything food tourman um
does it frustrate you and you're
reflecting on how to tackle how you've
got players who've generated
such pride from the country during these
last few weeks but you're still having
to deal and address the fact there are
fans who've been disrespectful offensive
and violent and
and not the image that you want and
certainly completely counter to the
image that
the players have presented
yeah look i mean we can't control that
um
we can only set the example that we
believe we should
and represent the country in the way
that
we feel um you should when you're
representing england and
everybody has to remember when they
support the team that they
also represent england and uh should
represent what we stand for
so um i think the the players have done
that brilliantly
and um we can only continue
to try to affect the things that we can
but
we have i think had a positive effect on
lots of areas of society but
but we can't affect everything there
other people have responsibilities in
those areas
and uh um you know
we've all got to work collectively to to
constantly improve those things
and we'll finish with a question from
ali foster at the bbc
[Music]
hi there gareth hi gareth apologies
um just as those players are really
hurting at the moment especially the
three that miss the penalties you say
you take their sort of collective
responsibility and responsibility as
well
how much does it hurt you that you
perhaps didn't get things right
about you talk about failing to solve
those problems that roberto mancini